[Musique]
en amour les coûts et les couleurs ne se
discutent pas normal c'est le coeur qui
commande
mais quand on flashe sur un garçon sur
une fille le premier coup d'oeil ne
pardonne pas seventies sport ou
classique
le look impose sa loi mais c'est le
plaisir des yeux qui nous incite à faire
le premier pas de fait doit avoir un
garçon et doit être en jean avec une
chemise un blouson en cuir et puis une
belle godasses
déjà moi la peau en chose que je regarde
c'est les chaussures je m'en fous ces
chaussures c'est pas intéressant
[Musique]
j'ai jamais craqué pour un garçon qui
soit mal habillés par exemple il ya une
chemise et puis plus le pardessus et la
chemise qui part à côté
on est obligé de regarder comment la
personne et habillez moi si une personne
morale est mignonne mais qui qui n'est
pas bien habillé je vais passer mon
chemin
si ce vote est mal habillé ma voix va
bien d'artois généralement on s'approche
pas des filles qui sont bloqués comme un
sage
[Musique]
j'aime pas les meufs qui sont avec ses
jeans baskets un garçon pour me plaire
d'une basket chemise assez cool quoi
pourquoi pas un pantalon à pince avec
eux des chaussures à talons une veste en
jean un billet classique
[Musique]
j'aimerais pas qu'ils soient trop
réservés cl je suis pas qu'aux stars et
tout ça quoi ces chartes alkire son
costard cravate je suis dur a plutôt dû
se détendent quoi ci dessus on va se
balader comme ça on peut rester cool
basket sweet comme ça mais si on va pour
draguer ou n'importe quoi il faut quand
même rappeler deux choses
[Musique]
ça m'arrive z un garçon une pas mignon
mais sur le comédien a habillé
[Musique]